if you've got somebody that's dragging
that's going down in a downward spiral
and you decide that you're just going to
pour everything into them well then
you're going to go down that downward
spiral as well and now you're not going
to be able to help them so i think
you definitely have to get yourself you
have to take care of yourself so that
you have the platform to take care of
someone else and help someone move in
the right direction oftentimes when you
think you're helping someone
you're really just enabling them you
know when people are in a case of
addiction
it's awful and the people that are
trying the loved ones that are trying to
help them by saying okay look i'll i'm
going to help you through i'm going to
give you a little bit more money right
now but this is the last time you got to
make sure that you're seeing the person
and the situation for what it really is
decide
whether this person can be helped
and
how
far you're willing to go to help them
you